when business projects fail to deliver
poor planning execution and
communication are often to blame with
organizations constantly working to
achieve their business goals and rapid
growth there is a need to fix obsolete
processes and embrace new technologies
to stay in the competition and business
analysis can help make organizations
more efficient productive and profitable
business analysts mentor businesses in
improving processes products services
and software through data analysis they
ensure that the organization is on track
to reach its goals so if you want to get
introduced to the important concepts and
skills needed for a career as a business
analyst we are here to help you with
that get prepared to start your business
analysis career with us simply learn
skill up course on business analysis
basics helps you learn the fundamentals
of business analysis for free yes you
heard it right free you can begin your
business analytics learning journey with
us free of cost and get a post
completion certificate for the sale let
us take you through the details of our
free business analysis basics course
simply learn skill up course on business
analysis basics is specially designed
for beginners who want to learn business
analysis fundamentals in the skill-up
course you will learn interesting skills
like planning and monitoring requirement
solicitation and requirements management
amp communication to name a few the
topics covered in this course are need
for a business analyst business analyst
roles and responsibilities skills
required to become a business analyst
business analysis knowledge areas
business analysis with excel and demo
business analyst versus data analyst and
interview questions and answers this
free skill up course gives you a
complete overview of the basics of
business analysis
the course duration is two hours and all
the modules are self-paced video lessons
with 90 days of access to the entire
course this allows you to learn at your
own pace at your convenience after
finishing this course you are awarded a
course completion certificate by simply
learn this certificate can be shared
within your professional circle isn't
that great so now you might be wondering
if you are eligible to take up this
course well yes you are as there are no
prerequisites to learn business analysis
for beginners this course is ideal for
writing professionals project managers
banking professionals marketing
professionals agile professionals and
program managers to name a few top
companies are paying more than hundred
thousand dollars for business analysts
so what are you waiting for head
straight to our scala page and enrich
your business analysis knowledge by
enrolling in our free business analysis
basics course today back this golden
opportunity and get certified with
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here